at 4 13
this morning i was awoken by a phone
call from john mcafee
who was calling to tell me that the
police were closing in he had spent the
night
in an undisclosed house in belize
sleeping on a bed
infested with lice and that he felt that
the end was near
that they would arrest him at any minute
but he was not going to surrender
because he was convinced that they would
kill him
i've been following mcafee's case in
belize for the past six months ever
since april 30th
when the police raided him and accused
him of being a drug trafficker
and possessing illegal firearms
over those six months i've spent weeks
in belize and interviewed mcafee both in
person
and on the telephone probably over 100
hours of interviews
and i can say without a doubt that he is
a very complex person
but whether or not he's a murderer is
yet to be seen
i recorded mcafee's phone calls to me
this morning with his permission and
what
follows are those calls one of the
charges against you
is that you're a psychopath what do you
have to say about that
well if i were a psychopath i would i
would not be confident to
uh to comment on it other than to say
yes or no
and either one if i were a psychopath
would be uh
irrelevant i do not think i'm a
psychopath i like people
i think psychopaths are sort of
anti-social folks that hate people i
tend to love people
i tend to love people in spite of their
faults in spite of
the things that they do or attempt to do
to me
you're well aware of of marcia for
example who
who plotted for for three months to um
they had me kidnapped for money and um
you know i i still talked to marcian and
she she lived with me after that
for for two additional months before it
finally got too intense
this is a good question why do you
surround yourself
uh with people of questionable character
well i surround myself with people of
unquestionable character too
eddie and cona i don't know a more
honest uh
god-fearing person um yourself i think i
befriended you
and and embraced you as i embraced
anyone else
i'm living in a country where most
people are questionable
i'm sorry for when i was at the river
uh i'm i'm right next to carmelita a
very poor district a very high crime
uh almost everybody steals well they're
the people i'm with i surround myself
and embrace wherever i
am um you know eddie and kona
your wife katrina um i have just as many
friends of high character as i do of low
i just don't discriminate
people are people you know i think that
people are
are a product of their conditioning you
know you take a person and put them in
an environment where everybody steals
you're beaten you starve you see your
family doing questionable things
that's what you do you follow the crowd
that doesn't mean that your heart your
soul is
is is violated to the point that you're
no longer human
it simply means that you know maybe you
can change maybe if you're loved enough
or embraced enough
uh your heart will open and you will see
a different path
unfortunately my experience has been
that very few
do but that doesn't mean that that i
should turn cynical and say well screw
it you know
you can't help anybody right and and
more specifically in terms of people
like eddie mccoy
you know who the government say is a
gangster of the highest level
why would you associate with him
well that association was kind of forced
on me i mean
eddie was actually hired to kill me and
over a period of
three months of dodging him simply got
to know his
uh his his character a little bit you
know and um
he's definitely a bad man um i associate
with him because
he among other things interests me i've
never seen anything like him i've never
imagined anything like eddie and my
association by the way you know
i don't sleep with him i don't i don't
hang out with him a lot
occasionally we we spend time
occasionally we talk
it's fascinating that you would like to
do it yourself if you if you could spend
an hour talking to eddie the way he
talks to me about the reality of his
life you would do it of course you would
write a story about it but
that's the question yeah
let's let's talk about um
the drugs the accusations uh that
you are dealing in drugs uh specifically
your postings about mdpv
uh which seem to indicate
right on blue light which seemed to
indicate that uh
you have produced 50 pounds of mdpv
well first of all i wouldn't know how to
produce 50 pounds of mdpv i'm not a
chemist
i actually almost failed organic
chemistry in college
probably less because of my intelligence
and more because of women but
i wouldn't know how i wouldn't have a
vegas clue now i mean that lab here
that's in the lab
you know i can i can i can do a dog and
pony show and punch and point to things
and give their names
who wouldn't have a clue how to use them
geez so
number one i wouldn't know how number
two for what purpose i don't know what
the price is or how you would market it
or anything else but
but there's got to be easier and and uh
cheaper ways to make money i mean
probably if i
if i were motivated to that extent that
i would start a lab
i'd write some software first you know
or at least design
some and pay someone a few dollars to
write it
would make more money right um
secondly i i i'm just violently opposed
to drugs i think that drugs
are the evil of the society they
they do we move to humanity i think that
you know people like tino
um who when he is sober and when he is
not on drugs
is honest to god a sweet man he is like
he did not drink he did not take drugs
the entire time he was at my house
doing the photographs for your magazine
sweet
respectful do you put a beer in him
or you put some cocaine in him or
whatever it is that he takes
he turns into a monster of the highest
order
he is the prototype of the drugged up
personality so why on earth you know
i'm stupid enough without drugs and my
life is up enough without drugs
and always has been
um i don't need to add to it sir and
the you know one of the allegations is
that during the time
that you've been in belize uh you've
become increasingly erratic
your behavior has become increasingly uh
unpredictable
to what do you attribute that well like
i would like you give me any human being
with any character
uh and you storm their house
without without warning shoot the dog
the one you love
well actually i love all my dogs it
treat them the way i've been treated and
then make
threats and then start harassing them
trust me
you become erratic and unpredictable
you know i most people may have done
worse i think i'm
because of my age and experience and you
know i'm a very balanced person and
trying to make
light off almost all situations didn't
happen to me
and trying to find humor in everything i
think i've survived this pretty well
but jesus josh you would be erratic
anybody would be wrecked
right now sir i am i am holed up in a
place where
by the way the my the mattress here has
uh one of the things that we're calling
on because rice
i've never experienced that before um
i'm holed up in this place i have
limited contact with anyone
hi there yeah i'm taking a huge risk
here i'm on my other phone
dude the number i the telephone ran out
of credit do you have
that number on your phone you want me to
call you back on it
try to call it back and see if i can get
it got it so
we were talking about stop by erratic
behavior
here in police yes okay
and uh and you said that essentially um
anybody would react as as you know as
you have
uh if they chose to stay here now most
people would react by going
uh i'm getting the hell out of here and
maybe my staying
is the erratic part that is
unintelligible i don't know
um but i'm here
and i am going through this and still
going through it yeah
um you know in terms of um of
the case with with greg fall
you know i think there's a presumption
of guilt at this point
in the public simply because
he lived two doors down from you he
he didn't like your dogs your dogs were
poisoned on friday night
it seems it's possible that you found
out that he
poisoned them and uh and took revenge
again and we've spoken about this before
the idea that my neighbors may have done
it did in fact occur with me one of them
and then the first one was the doctor
next door because he lives closest to me
greg lives
way down the beach and i was even
surprised he could even hear my dogs
but both of these both greg and the
doctor
have dogs love dogs a dog
owner a dog lover is not going to poison
anybody's dog under any circumstances
now maybe they poisoned me
but not my dogs it just
just not possible i did talk to the
caretaker next door that knows both
of his name is william and william said
no this is no way and i go yeah i didn't
think so i agree
so i i don't know that's absurd and you
didn't find out any more information on
saturday that made you suspect
greg absolutely not
yeah and uh
you know as to your speculations of of
what might have happened to him
i do not have a clue the only
information i have about him is what
you'd have told me
and what i think cash or priscilla had
told me
um i had no idea that that he was he was
shot execution style
i heard some things were missing
you're the one that told me was a nine
millimeter shell yeah
all i know i had no speculation other
than the first thing i thought about
was oh my god he's a white man i'm a
white man
someone's you know the government's
finally decided to off me
they got the wrong white man since we're
so you know we live almost next door
and that actually went through my mind
and actually scared me for quite a while
right
and do you know
what's the end game at this point
well you know i don't have a clue sir um
i am
you know i'm i am unable to move that's
clear
my face is mastered all all the police
all the all the
bdf have my photo um i'm
but you know it's a small country like i
have a white man with a unique features
um if i leave this house i would be
identified instantly
and then nabbed so for the for
the foreseeable future this is my home
um
and actually someone just had a birthday
i just looked it says happy birthday
and there's a name which i won't give
you it's this this is in the kitchen
area
yeah um i just noticed that i just
turned around
and um this is going to be my home i
don't know what the end game is the end
game is
obviously given enough time they will
track me down
i have to eat i have to have supplies
i'm using a telephone they will
eventually figure out which phone and
triangulate it
you know it's just a matter of time in
the meantime i'd like to get out as much
information as i can
about the wrongs in this country and the
wrongs by the way aren't the people
this the the people are you know in in
spite of
the poverty and the theft and the petty
crimes the people are truly
truly beautiful the country i've never
seen
a more spectacular place it is
it is the the destination of heaven
the problem is political
it's a brand new country it hasn't found
its footing yet
and the politicians by and large tend to
enrich themselves
at the expense of the country as a whole
this is the only problem we have here
and the problem that i'm not going to
play that game and i'm not going to go
along with it i'm not going to keep
quiet about it
why do you think they're targeting you
why why why do you think the government
is targeting you well because
number one i i'm one of the first um
foreigners to live here that actually
has you know
uh bumped up against the government and
then i have access to
to the press and panhand for a long time
uh and that's my only my only weapon
really and so i talk
and i tell the truth and it it's it
sheds a very negative light i mean for
example
in this country now they can try you
without a jury
meaning you can be charged first of all
they can hold you for 30 days without
even charging you
then you can be charged and the prime
minister or cabinet minister can choose
an appropriate judge to judge you
and the judge can judge you any way he
wishes no jury
no due process this is where we stand
and this is what's going to happen to me
by the way when i'm caught
there will i will be held without
charges if i
survive the 30 days which i doubt very
strongly
but lots of people do you know die in
prison here from
in a strangle on their own vomit hanging
in themselves because they're too
miserable
getting beaten to death by fellow
inmates
or a variety of other things and then of
course it's not the government's fault
well you know he did wrong he got
arrested and something happened to him
um but if if i do survive that 30 days
then some judge will go
you're guilty period right this is where
we are
this is not this is not the this is not
what should be happening in the most
beautiful country in the world
shouldn't be shouldn't be and
tell me more about what you perceive to
be the
the failings of the government
well you know beliefs was founded by
pirates
the the the offspring of those
pirates still reside here and uh
the country has an attitude that's
that's the pirate attitude you know the
uh governed by fear um
you we collect our dues by extortion
um we we enforce through brutality
uh and we get what we can we take our
booty as it comes and and that's the
attitude of the
the government and the ministers to an
extreme
um so the corruption the
the disregard for fellow man in terms of
the the the country outside of your own
family
is the fundamental problem that can
change it has changed throughout
throughout history in many countries
talk about why you came to belize in the
first place
i retired to police because to me it's
physically the most beautiful country on
earth a barrier reef
protects the shoreline and allows
residents to build piers and enjoy
the the seashore as if it were a calm
lake
most of the year the water is a
crystal aquamarine blue on sunny days
that just
invites you to come into it uh the the
fishing
the boating swimming and snorkeling is
is is superb beyond anything i've
imagined
the interior of the country the rivers
the jungles crocodiles
birds wildlife profoundly
attractive to me the people
simple in most cases um
and and and welcoming it's it to me
where else would i retire yeah
let's see some of you will take through
some of the other allegations here
yes sir hi
uh so i guess one question is
if it's inevitable that they will
get you why not
get a lawyer and turn yourself in
okay the last high profile person to
turn themselves
in was shot in fact in police custody
his name was arthur young
his handcuffs were tied where he had his
hands cut behind his back
and they shot him right
so the legal system there you don't have
faith in
in in in the due process
well now that now that the constitution
has been
unraveled by the prime minister there is
no due process there is no
legal recourse the the cabinet can
override the
the judicial system apparently and the
judicial system
is loyal to the party rather than
through the law in many cases
out of fear not because the judges are
are corrupt but the judges are afraid
um everybody is afraid if you do not tow
the party line
then retribution comes either at the
hands of
the gsu which is the strong arm of the
prime minister
or through financial or other
catastrophe
um so no sir i i do not
right
um okay what what else i think that
basically covers oh yeah there wasn't i
remember
okay i would like to say one thing i i
think that the american public needs to
notice that
that there are innocent people uh
extremely
fine people who are at right now
suffering in jail
undoubtedly undergoing torture of of
some sort that leaves no scars
um that need to be released um
you know i'm the one that they want and
and holding my friends
um is not going to get them anywhere so
um
i would just like to say that sir right
one of um my friends by name eddie
ancona
cassian chavarria um
william mulligan uh and i do not know
cesar the taxi driver's last
name his only crime was driving me from
my house
into town and these are people
i'm sorry these are people who have been
arrested and are still being held and
you know you know what happens in
central american jails
in order to get information so i fully
expect
to have science statements saying that
you know god knows what
uh that yes if he had the gun we saw him
have the gun he told everybody whatever
but you know who wouldn't i would do it
myself if you put enough
pain on someone they will say or sign
anything
right um
but these people need to be released
and i would like to implore the prime
minister to do the right thing
and release them right
some of the other allegations uh that
have cropped up
uh detail your
um uh discussions of yours
one allegation which you did not address
is here in this country everyone is
saying well you know the reason that he
returns
to drugs is because the young girl that
he hangs with
got him into drugs i think you know that
the reverse
is absolutely true okay i'm i'm here
with sam who
sam can say when's the last time you had
any drugs or alcohol
it's been a while because i will not
hang with them if they continue to drink
and do drugs
this is a fact you know this um
you've been with me so it's they're not
turning me on to drugs i'm turning them
off of drugs uh and it's a requirement
of
my my condition you know you're not
gonna not gonna be hanging with me if
you're drinking and drugging it's a fact
well one of the the allegations are that
not that um
you're you're drinking or that you're
using traditional
uh narcotics but that you're using
drugs such as mdpv uh that are
libido enhancers here drugs aren't drugs
uh the the libido enhancers that i use i
will be frank with you i sometimes do
use
viagra okay i don't know that it
enhances my libido but it does
enhance my my virility okay
but drugs and drugs anything that that
that modifies
your consciousness uh warps your
perceptions is a drug i don't care
maybe you say coffee does that i don't
know but i do drink coffee
but but still drugstore drugs i don't
care what the name is
and you know these allegations that you
use drugs to get women to
to sleep with you or that for you to
keep up with younger women
okay i am a rich man in a poor country
um you know and um i still have some
small amount of charisma left i
i hope i will never have to resort to
drugging women to get them to sleep with
me
yeah so
anyway sir i need to i need to get off
of this one again
we can take a little time here i'll put
this
stuff online